bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pourquoi la
pandémie ne faiblit pas au brésil alors
c'est pas tout à fait vrai de dire
qu'elle ne faiblit pas effectivement on
n'a pas encore atteint le pic
globalement dans le pays
mais il ya certaines régions certains
états ou effectivement ça commence à
diminuer ou à se stabiliser
notamment dans le pernambuco nord ouest
notamment dans l'état d'amazonas à rio
il semble qu'il ya aussi quelques
frémissements
alors qu'elle semble par l'eau ça
continue à augmenter donc c'est
extrêmement variable d'un endroit à
l'autre
mais il est clair qu'on n'est pas au
bout au brésil et que la politique
sanitaire adoptée par le gouvernement
n'aide pas à circonscrire le virus il va
finalement suivre son chemin tout seul
avec encore pas mal de mort avant de
s'essouffler est ce que vous voulez dire
que les mesures qui sont prises par les
autorités sanitaires et les pouvoirs
publics au brésil ne servent pas
finalement à faire face à cette pandémie
non dire qu'on a d'un côté un président
qui nie toujours la pandémie continue à
dire que c'est une grippe est que la
crise économique est beaucoup plus grave
et qu'il faut remettre les gens au
travail
on a des gouverneurs des états qui eux
continuent à maintenir les gens
confinement là où c'est nécessaire
donc on n'a pas une politique cohérente
à ce niveau là d'autre part les moyens
de lutte sont extrêmement faibles
les gens notamment chez les plus pauvres
ne peuvent pas se confiner chez eux
parce qu'ils ont travaillé pour manger
donc le confinement globalement il est
en dessous de 50% brésil donc avec ça
effectivement le virus continue à se
répandre la politique
adopté par la stratégie ont fait adopter
par derrière boissons a rossé le
déconfinement est-ce qu'on a des confiné
beaucoup trop tôt dans ce pays on peut
pas dire ça non plus parce que ça dépend
des états c'est à dire que finalement
les directives données par jallet bel
subaru ne sont pas nécessairement suivi
comme elle devrait l'être dans les
différents états donc il ya des états où
on peut se dire que ça avec on finit un
peu trop vite on s'inquiète d'ailleurs
du fait qu'à rio maintenant on commence
avec on finit un peu trop d'autres qui
déconfit plus prudemment comme le
pernambouc
donc il est encore difficile d'avoir une
vision globale de la situation et de
savoir exactement pourquoi la pandémie
ne s'arrête pas sinon qu effectivement
il ya plus que du flou dans la manière
dont elle est gérée par les autorités
c'est vrai que le brésil fonctionne
comme un état fédéral est-ce que les
directives du président de l'aéro son
art aux ont suivi véritablement la
lettre est ce qu'il ya des oppositions
au président brésilien
il ya énormément d'opposition il y en a
partout les boues il n'a plus que 30% de
de popularité mais la popularité de gens
qui sont très ancrés avec lui il est
contesté au parlement il est contesté
par le tribunal suprême
il y as derrière un certain nombre de
demandes de pitch mène contre lui dans
quête qui sont menées contre lui et sa
famille mais tout ça ne fait pas encore
une crise politique suffisant pour que
l'on puisse dire qu'ils risquent
vraiment sa place
donc on est plutôt dans un espèce de
marasme et d'impasse politique qui est
aussi lié au fait que l'opposition est
totalement désorganisée et que rien
vraiment ça il ya des soubresauts mais
rien n'avance vraiment et l'opinion
publique dans tout cela
alors l'opinion publique en fait elle et
d'opinions favorables à jaillir ball
sonar hausse est toujours un petit noyau
jean qui situe très à l'extrême droite
de l'échiquier politique mais qui sont
toujours l'infidèle
il ya un immense marais de gens qui sont
finalement sans opinion ou en tout cas
pas activement avec une opinion c'est
une opposition on peut dire une
opposition constituée qui est totalement
éclaté hier l'ancien président fernando
henrique cardoso appelait à toutes les
forces démocratiques à s'unir pour faire
face à la situation sanitaire est
politique mais dans les faits ça ne se
passe pas c'est à dire qu'on est
effectivement fasse plus à une un
panorama politique totalement éclatée
qui reste favorable pour le moment à
bolton à rots que à quelque chose qui
est en train de bouger
merci beaucoup à vous jean jacques à
fontanes je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste du brésil